OK, let's continue, as has been a very, very
busy 24 hours, Donald Trump, as I mentioned
yesterday, had this super low energy corona
virus press briefing.
It was just bad.
He seemed deflated.
He took only a few questions, mostly from
friendly reporters.
And then after smearing Kamala Harris and
mispronouncing her name, he just sort of stalked
off the stage in the way really I've only
ever seen Donald Trump do.
Very, very strange sort of dynamics and posture
to it.
And, of course, what comes out of his mouth
is not much better, apparently feeling like
he needed a booster.
Last night, Donald Trump called into the Sean
Hannity propaganda program on Fox News to,
I guess, sort of try to have a better showing
than he did during the press briefing.
But what's not been working out super well
for Trump on Fox News is that he gets fed
the most softball of softball questions and
he still manages to either mess it up or say
something that actually acutely worsens the
situation for him.
And it's like nobody can make the guy look
good.
Almost nobody.
Although I'll tell you at the end of the segment
who I do think manages to make Trump look
less bad.
And Trump went on Fox News spoke to Sean Hannity
last night, calling from the White House,
trying to take some of the attention back
from the news cycle of Joe Biden selecting
Kamala Harris to be his running mate.
And it was really weird and it was really
bad.
And once again, I have to ask, how is it that
these interviews keep happening again and
again and again?
Clearly, we know that the people around Donald
Trump have no control over him, but also even
the friendly interviews go bad, like even
Sean Hannity, who's Trump's friend and is
not interested in anything that we would call
journalism when it comes to Donald Trump.
Even he can't get Trump a sensible interview.
So let's look at some of these and hope that
in a few months, this type of nonsense from
the Oval Office, because that's what this
is.
This is not, you know, some as as as some
like to pejoratively call them.
This is not some basement show with two viewers
interviewing some unknown person.
This is FOX News interviewing the president
of the United States, hopefully in a few months.
This type of nonsense regularly coming from
the Oval Office emanating from the Oval Office
will be relegated to the archives as this
happened.
And it's now in the past rather than the day
to day.
First, here is Donald Trump insisting that
this is going to be a rigged election and
this has worked.
Later in the program, I'm going to tell you
about new polling that confirms this strategy
from Trump of saying it's going to be rigged.
It's not going to be fair.
It has worked.
And it could actually lead to chaos during
Election Day, election week.
Maybe we should be calling it.
I'll explain that later.
But here is Trump himself saying it is common
sense and an absentee ballot.
OK, will you send in for a ballot?
They go through a process and they send it
to you.
Then you send it.
It's fine.
But these mail in ballots where they send
millions of them all over the country.
So it's going to be a rigged election.
And this country shouldn't allow it.
The courts have to step in when many different
courts right now.
If the court should step in the federal courts,
you'll never know who won the election.
Just so this is now on repeat.
This is just that he's saying it multiple
times a day.
Trump pretending, first of all, that there
is a difference in practice between absentee
and mail in voting.
Now, every time this comes up, somebody will
e-mail me and they'll say, David, there is
a difference between absentee and mail in
voting.
There is a difference in theory.
OK.
We could have a universal mail in voting system
that would be different from absentee voting
this time around.
When we talk about mail in voting, what we
mean is expanding absentee voting, which Trump
says is OK so that everybody can get an absentee
ballot in some states.
This means sending everybody a ballot who's
registered, not dogs, not undocumented immigrants.
In other states, it means sending everybody
who's registered an application for an absentee
ballot.
In other states, it means you still have to
apply.
But saying I'm worried about catching Corona
virus would be a valid reason to vote absentee
when traditionally in many elections you would
not have that freedom.
You would have to.
Your reason for wanting an absentee ballot
would have to be justified in another way.
So again, Trump pretending there's a difference
operationally, practically, there is no difference
between mail in and absentee this time around.
And again, Trump does allude to the various
lawsuits that he's filing.
That is a real concern that actually might
work to gum everything up.
And we're going to talk about.
Later as well, in my segment on the strategy
to steal the election.
That's coming up later.
We'll continue in our sort of tour of the
horrors of this interview last night.
Here is Donald Trump complaining.
I mean, he's just so whiny.
Have you ever seen a supposed Alpha complain
and whine as much as Donald Trump saying he
was impeached over his so-called perfect phone
call?
A disgrace.
They play a much dirty game.
They'll impeach you over a phone call.
That was perfect.
Nothing like that's ever happened before.
They impeached me over a phone call that was
absolutely perfect.
You couldn't have made a better phone call.
There was nothing done wrong with that phone
call.
And they play a much dirtier game, a much
tougher game than the Republicans.
What do you think it's like being Hannity
in these interviews?
I'm not saying I envy the guy.
And I'm also not saying I feel bad for the
guy.
I'm just saying.
What do you think?
It's like you're you're Trump's friend.
Hannity is Trump's friend.
Hannity gives Trump the softest of softball
interviews.
You can barely.
You can't call it journalism.
You can barely call it an interview.
And Trump still goes off the rails into these
disjointed, aimless tangents.
Does Hannity worry that, like, wow.
I'm not even doing anything that we would
call journalism.
And still, Trump doesn't look good.
And then somehow Trump gets onto the topic
of ranting about Pulitzer Prizes and New York
Times reporter Maggie Haberman.
It's so weird what Trump gets obsessed with.
Anonymous sources.
Also a topic.
Take a look.
They got it wrong and they got Pulitzer Prizes,
the Pulitzer Prize worthless as far as I'm
concerned, because when you have the Maggie
Haberman is getting a Pulitzer Prize and she
got it all wrong.
She doesn't.
I haven't spoken to her in forever.
She's like my biographer.
Like, she knows everything about me.
She knows nothing about me.
And they talk about they have sources.
They don't have sources that made up.
They make them up in their mind.
They have no sources.
I know when there are sources.
But if you look at the times and I guess The
Washington Post, they got Pulitzer Prizes
and they were totally wrong.
Imagine being so arrogant that you think you
know about any story a newspaper publishes,
whether there are really sources or not.
Now, for I'm not going to bore you again with
the confusion that Trump has had for years
about what anonymous sources are.
Remember, Trump doesn't seem to understand
the difference between a source that's anonymous
in the sense that a media outlet doesn't publish
their name versus a source that is anonymous
to the reporter.
OK.
In almost all cases, when we talk about an
anonymous source, what we mean is the reporter
knows who the sources, but they are not publishing
the identity of that source.
Trump, in many cases seems to think the reporters
don't know who it is that they are dealing
with.
Anyway, the level of arrogance and narcissism
is really something else.
And then here is Trump.
On the same day that we have the first woman
of color as a presidential or vice presidential
candidate in the United States insisting he's
done more, more good.
I've done more is is one aspect of it, but
done more good for black people than anyone
other.
Of course, other than Abraham Lincoln, as
he likes to say, I've done more for the black
community than any other president other than
perhaps Abraham Lincoln.
Now, here's just a final little thing.
Donald Trump still unable to say the word
Minneapolis, send in the National Guard and
solve the problem like we did in Minneapolis.
Just every interview.
I mean, you have the full spectrum.
Mostly you have a spectrum of Jonathan Swann
pushing back in the Axios interview last Monday
night, all the way to.
On the other side, Sean Hannity just letting
Trump rant.
And he never makes sense.
He never looks good.
He can never hold it together, no matter what
the setup, no matter how freely an uninterruptedly
he's allowed to just say whatever he wants.
Sometimes I actually think the interviews
where Trump comes out looking best and I alluded
to this before.
We've seen Trump on Fox News, Fox and Friends,
Hannity, Jeanine Pirro.
We've seen the gamut.
We've seen Trump in press briefings.
We've seen Trump with George Stephanopoulos
and with Jonathan.
So it's always a disaster.
Trump comes out looking the best where understand
the level of babysitting that has to be done
by by the interviewer.
Trump comes out the best on interviews, for
example, with the Christian Broadcasting Network.
Now, I'm not saying that when Trump is interviewed
by CBN, he makes sense or he explains.
Policy or any of that?
What I am saying is.
Just letting Trump rant is it's bad for Trump.
He looks bad.
CBN goes further on CBN.
The interviewers will sometimes rephrase what
Donald Trump says to make him look coherent.
That's the level of involvement you need from
an interview or even a friendly interviewer
to make Donald Trump look good.
It's not just don't challenge him.
It's.
Don't challenge him and then rephrase his
answers and respond to them like he's being
insightful or intelligent or coherent.
And the place that does that is Christian
Broadcasting Network.
There's probably some other I think that he
did an interview with some guy from barstool
sports.
I didn't even know the guy, but that was a
couple of weeks ago where, again, Trump wasn't
making any sense.
It was a friendly interview.
But the guy who interviewed Dave Portnoy,
I believe his name was Dave Portnoy.
Dave Portnoy.
If I'm remembering correctly, would actually
react and respond as if Trump was making sense.
And that's the degree of help Trump neat Trump
needs in order to come out of an interview
looking even semi coherent.
It's incredible, incredible that that's where
we are today.
Let's take a quick break.
Remember that you can follow me on Twitch
for frequent live streams.
I will say at Twitch dot TV slash David Pakman
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.